his new book bracketology march madness
college basketball and the creation of a
national obsession is available now
wherever books are sold
i guess it's tax season if you will for
this man in a way it's bracketology's
own
joe lenardi from the worldwide leader in
sports how are you joe
rich it's great to talk to you great to
talk to you so
do you have like a board up uh on the
wall like if anybody's ever seen
homeland or anything like that
it's it looks like that where you got
conspiracy theories on the wall and
you've got it's all attached by string i
mean how do you
figure this whole thing out right now
joe what's your life like right now well
i don't
put red x's through you know undesirable
very good very good that's uh i like it
but i might put
green circles around desirable okay
yeah no look uh my job and and a lot of
people still don't maybe get this isn't
to put teams in or out of projecting
center out
as if i were giving you my opinion
because there's a hundred people a
thousand people on tv who are more than
willing to do that
and they're very good at it my job is to
say what those ten people are gonna do
in the committee room given the the
results
and the teams and the set of
circumstances that's facing them right
now today
as they're going over everybody's resume
and that's a little bit more of a
technical thing and
a lot of fans don't like that
but i think it's important to shine a
light on that process if only because
you know rich and you remember way back
in the day this was
generally not the most transparent thing
in the world yes
and a lot of players and coaches and
media and ads and
conference people would just kind of
walk away scratching their heads
so uh joe linare here on the rich eisen
show a first for you a first for
everybody
um with this bubble community that's
being uh built in indianapolis
is uh what i assume uh
is is happening with virginia right now
uh one of the
one of the teams out of the acc that
worked would expect to be
in the the dance next week now out of
the acc
tournament they have to test negative
for seven straight days which would
which would be in time for march madness
that is going to begin on a friday
uh after the the first four if you will
so
what do you think the committee will
will think about this i mean how do you
factor all this in with what's going on
with virginia
joe yeah it's i mean i'd like to say
that there's some precedent here but
of course there isn't and i think you
know just from a
counting standpoint virginia could also
be given a first
round pairing that plays on saturday
right
uh either friday or saturday i mean i
suppose
taking it to an extreme they could play
the last
of the 32 first-round games at you know
like
10 o'clock saturday night a week from
now or a week in a day from now and that
would give
you know what is the defending champion
from the last time we had a tournament
right
you're right the greatest opportunity to
uh you know test their way back
into playing but as i understand it
uh that they have to make that
commitment to the ncaa
uh there's a deadline and and i don't
know
whether you know at what point does the
ncaa go to one of its four
kind of standby teams who are going to
be identified on selection sunday as
well
uh nobody's talking either from the
virginia side or the ncaa side
because they probably didn't think about
the scenario quite this way i'm i'm
reminded of the year
uh where there was a tornado
at the sec tournament and
uh games were cancelled to georgia dome
and
uh uh the university of georgia
ended up playing a quarterfinal and a
semi-final
in the same day one at georgia tech one
back at the dome
and eventually then on sunday one the
automatic bid like
talk about taking it down to the wire i
i don't think we're gonna know about
virginia
uh on selection sunday at least
there's a possibility that we won't and
before we get into um
you know seeds and teams first team in
last team out and all that
i mean last team in first team out sort
of stuff i mean things are different for
this tournament where the first
round the round of 64 in the round of 32
is going to be a friday and a saturday
and then the second round
um is going to be a sunday and then a
monday
and then the sweet 16 is a saturday and
a sunday
right i mean so yep so it's going to
really go it's going to go friday
through monday first weekend and then
second sweet 16 is going to be a
saturday and sunday like i guess we're
used to
the elite date's going to be a monday
and a tuesday so
things are a little bit different but
what do you mean for those who might not
know
that there's gonna be you know i guess
in case of covid break
glass four teams that are have a bubble
get i guess popped but they're hoping
for a
for a pandemic chance is that literally
what what's gonna happen here
yeah the the you know several years ago
the ncaa actually is part of an
anti-trust
uh litigation became
the the controller of the nit as well
and
so so the n i t committee
is basically given its four number one
seeds
by the teams identified by the ncaa
committee
as the first four out so those first
four out
will be if they choose kind of on
standby
uh and they can be
added to the ncaa field
as late as the wednesday before the
first four begins
next friday or excuse me next thursday
first four begins next thursday
the full bracket next friday uh like you
rich i'm confused
by the new calendar no sure but you know
our body clocks have been set this way
for
you know since 1985 right which is what
your book's about forgive us yes
and and and you know let's say
virginia decides to go or or the ncaa
agrees that they can go
but then something else happens between
selection sunday night and wednesday
and virginia has to opt out then the
first team on the contingency list is
going to go in virginia's spot
regardless of seat
they're not going to they're not going
to redo the whole bracket
the night before teams are supposed to
start playing so somebody
somebody that's not on par of the
caliber of virginia might get virginia's
seed
spot essentially correct take it to an
extreme
somebody could get team number 69 could
get gonzaga spot
right right so like realistically what
what more could they right it's better
than a forfeit
or a no contest or a walk over whatever
you want to call it
right uh you know
nobody said this was going to be perfect
nobody said it was going to be
fair and you know it was a year ago
today that they canceled the whole
tournament right
so you know i'm trying to look at the
cup as half full
joe lennardi here on the rich eisen show
he's got a new book called bracketology
march madness college basketball and the
creation
of a national obsession where all books
are sold you can get it and we'll talk
about that in a second
but let's talk about the here and now if
you don't mind joe uh your top overall
is gonzaga as you just referenced right
there
um who are your one seeds does does my
alma mater have to win to get a one seed
because
it looks like you've got two big ten
teams in his one seeds right now as
we're talking
here in michigan is playing right now uh
illinois will play later they're the
number three overall
and the number four overall and and rich
i think it's
extremely unlikely that the number one
seats change
at this point uh and it's it's
mostly coincidence that that cut line
uh is right at four right like
you know in a given year we might have
two or three teams maybe even five or
six that have kind of separated from the
rest
and we fight about the one seat right
but
this year it happened before and maybe
that's just a little bit of a gift from
the
the basketball god you know who've been
a little cruel
and you know in this case uh
maybe the order could change michigan
and illinois but
you know i i i think they're all but
locked with of course baylor and gonzaga
has one
and and two okay so then who's already
played their
their way in whether how they finish the
regular season or
just the mere smattering of games we've
seen conference wide
and who uh needs to play
well this weekend today and this weekend
in order to assure themselves of a spot
joe if you'd asked me a week ago
i would have told you there was next to
no chance that syracuse was going to be
in the ncaa tournament
uh but here they are and they're going
to make it
uh they're just going to make it but
there's almost no set of circumstances
now
where you know seven or eight things
would have to go wrong
which would be like pulling a quarter
out of your pocket and trying to flip
head
eight times in a row okay right like
that that's pretty hard
and we'd wait a while if you and i took
a coin out and tried that now
but you know wouldn't make for great
broadcasting i suppose
uh but but but you know
syracuse got hot at the end they beat
clemson and caroline at home in the
regular season
they won a 50-50 game against nc state
uh to open the acc tournament and then
they took virginia to the wire
yesterday that was only yesterday
and now virginia's out and syracuse is
still
at least alive for the committee if not
in in the bracket in greensboro
and you know we've seen them we've seen
this movie before where
behind makes it in late and is not just
the thorn in team
side in 2016 i had them as team number
69
they got in and went to the final four
and
needless to say i have not been welcomed
back to central new york since then
okay so then who needs to who needs to
play well to get in
just throw some out of it i i'll give
you a classic
elimination game it rarely falls this
perfectly but at midnight tonight
midnight eastern in the mountain west
the last two teams in the field on our
board
which are uh colorado state and utah
state
are playing in the mountain west
quarterfinal
they split in the regular season
conveniently enough
and now they're gonna play the rubber
game and you know it makes the most
sense to me to leave the winner in
and the loser goes home so for those two
teams
the ncaa tournament starts at midnight
joe linardi here on the rich eisen show
and your last four in drake colorado
state syracuse utah state why is ole
miss st
louis boise state and seton hall the
last four out right now
i mean we're talking almost invisible
distinctions here
you know st louis being the most unusual
case because
a they've been done for a week
uh because the atlantic 10 tournament
was played a week earlier
in order to give its teams some wiggle
room
if they had a virginia type situation
so credit the a-10 leadership for that
uh
a bit of clairvoyance if you will
and st louis also had
the longest pause in college basketball
this year
they didn't play a game for 42 days
they didn't play from before christmas
until the day before the super bowl
they only got 10 league games in but
before all that
they beat nc state they beat lsu
they beat saint bonaventure which is the
number one seed in their own league
and and they have you know some pretty
decent computer ratings uh not great but
good enough
yet it's very hard to evaluate a team
that played
a third fewer games than anyone else but
now
as teams kind of fall by the wayside
here either on the court
for those reasons or for off the court
pandemic reason
all of a sudden things are looking up
there and saying
so before i let you go joe what do you
want people to know about your book
because obviously they know you they
know your love for the sport they know
you're
your intensity and respect your
knowledge
for such a crucial moment is the putting
the brackets together that we're going
to have our hands on
uh this weekend which is a national
obsession we have not
uh we actually went a year without so a
perfect timing for your book and for us
to get back into this passion of uh
bracketology
joe thanks rich i i and to be honest i
i i've been approached before about
maybe doing a book
and i i was always reluctant because
frankly i didn't think anybody would be
interested in a book about me
uh i i'm not really interested in a book
about
you uh but but i was convinced and and
had a great
co-authoring in david's mail out of
kansas city i i
i was convinced that it wouldn't be
about me it would be about this
fun and this crazed
passion that people have even before the
tournament starts
right about who's in and who's out and
why and where
and and you know it like liquid when we
grew up rich it was a hot stove league
for baseball right
and now now this is the hot stove water
cooler for college basketball
and uh it it's just remarkable that it
has taken off
the the the way that it has i i never
could have predicted it i didn't
predict it there was no plan i'm not
that smart
and this book kind of tells
that story hopefully in a way
in which we take the content
seriously without lord taking
me seriously because uh
you know i i certainly don't deserve
what's the best story you've heard about
somebody who finished last in a
tournament
in the punishment that they received
what's the best story you've heard of
such a thing
joe well i once finished last in my own
house i lost to a cocker spaniel
uh say what honest honest to goodness
like you know with with
when my girls were little and we'd do
the old family pool and yep
you know they decided to enter one for
the dog he picked all the teams with dog
nicknames
against all the cats and yukon beats
kentucky to win it all
[Applause]
this actually happened
and i'm supposed to be the expert so how
often do dogs finish better than cats uh
in a bracket because you know we're
we're we're more dog people than cat
people on the rich eisen show here with
uh
bracketology march madness college
basketball and the creation of a
national obsession enjoy the
busy weekend joe and uh let's talk
during the tournament let's see what
your two cents are on the whole subject
i would love that thanks for having me
you got it that is joe linardi get it
where all books are sold
how great is that dogs versus cats
dogs beat the cats huskies beat wildcats
right there
that was pretty funny there you go oh my
gosh
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here